alright Andres what would Buddha be
doing if he was alive today you know
there's this fascinating misconception
that the Buddha kind of laid out all of
his teachings and said this is it but
that's not the case actually the Buddha
said continue improving them after I'm
not here and I think if the Buddha was
alive today he would be really
interested in figure and water like the
largest effect sizes for possible
transformative experiences and ways of
modifying our nervous system that get
rid of dukkha on unpleasant suffering
and I think it would be researching how
consciousness works in its
interrelationship with the brain with
cutting-edge paradigms of neuroscience
and specifically it would be looking at
things that cause some of the you know
best meditative States an example of it
being 5ml DMT just largest effect size
that we know of when it comes to
introducing you into for example what it
might be described as kind of a
extremely high concentration state or a
janna state and simply because we have
these very large effect sizes I think
like that it can clearly change the
world for the better in the direction
that Buddha was pushing but in a
scientifically grounded way and in a
much more generalizable way so I think
that's what what I would be doing would
be studying consciousness scientifically
and seeing what 21st century scientific
techniques can be used to eradicate
suffering yes